hello everyone and welcome to a really
nice game that was played last week I
believe in the in chest coms title
tuesday tournament between Vaslav and
chuck and greg Shehadeh now
Chucky needs no introduction but for
those of you who don't know greg he's an
international master from Philadelphia
who has a lifelong goal to crush the
Scandinavian defense and he will often
tweet about this for example here is one
such tweet there you have it this is
what Greg posted before his match with
the John Bartholomew in the 'i'm not
Aegean chess championship on chess calm
he says this is the guy who's gonna
crush the scandi tomorrow referring to
the Scandinavian defense and now I'm not
gonna spoil anything for you if you
haven't seen the match but do check it
out if you haven't it was very
interesting so that being said let's
check out the game now Turkey with the
white pieces opens what's that opens
with E for and here we have an hoping
that we don't see all that often we have
E 5 by Greg Knight f3 Knight to c6 and
d4 chalky goes for the Scotch game we
have eek a person before and now not
recapturing but gambling the pawn at the
Guren gambit which Greg accepts and now
Knight captures on c3 in the olden days
you would even gambit one more pawn with
Bishop to c4 which gives white a lot of
development already you have Bush was
developed but over over time black
realized that there really isn't
aren't any problems here so white isn't
really playing this all that much so
instead just knife characters and c3
some development for a pawn and d6 now
by Greg if you don't want to develop
your Bishop all the way then d6 makes
sense you wanna now play Bishop e7
Knight f6 Castle bringing the bishop
into the game and so on
so Bishop to c4 now with the pawn C pawn
gambit is wait Chuck he wants to play
Bishop c4 Queen b3 put pressure on the
f7 pawn Knight g5 bring more pressure
and this is a this is the idea so Knight
to f6 continuing development we have
Queen to b3 now pressuring the f7 pawn
and Queen d7 just defending the point
and not night
g5 adding a third attacker to the f7
pawn and now you could defend it with
both 98 and 95 95 is a little bit better
as it also attacks the whites
LightSquared Bishop here and it's a much
more active square for the knight so but
should be 5 now threatening the Queen
and c6 and now if you don't want to move
the bishop back you play f4 which is
what chalky plays and now the knight is
under attack and here black has a lot of
options and I'm pretty sure as since
this is a blitz game that it's something
Chucky I had in his home lab quote quite
a few times as here black can go night
Knight to g4 he could go Knight to g6
even h6 is an idea where you temporarily
sacrifice a piece for example captures
captures and now White's King is still
in the center of the board the knight is
under attack the bishop is under attack
and black will be doing fine here
however Greg went for C characters on b5
he went for the trade right away F
captures on e5 and now D captures on e5
and now Bishop to e3 making room for the
rook to come to d1 to put more pressure
on on blacks position here we have h6
trying to get the night away as long as
the knight is in g5 and the Queen and b3
you constantly have to worry about the
f7 pawn so of course Greg wants to kick
it away but first a nice in-between move
rook to d1 attacking the Queen and now
Queen to e7 if you go Queen to c7 then
just Knight B 5 wins the game on the
spot Queen e7 and our Bishop to c5 the
Queen has no more squares from from
where she can keep an eye on the f7 pawn
and if you capture leadership then Queen
captures and f7 is checkmate so this is
game over
so instead Greg wants the e7 and now now
Bishop to c5 isn't as strong because
black has Bishop to e6 which also
attacks whites Queen
so instead Chuckie goes Queen captures
on b5 and now Knight to d7
Bishop to d7 is in fact is in fact
better better here just attacking the
Queen and after captures you bring the
rook into the game later on you're going
to move the Queen move the bishop and
finally castle
however Greg went for night
to be seven and this puts black in in a
very in a pretty bad situation as the d5
square is no longer guarded by the night
so here a chuck immediately grabs the
outpost for the night Knight to d5 comes
with an attack on the Queen and now
Queen to d8 and now what do you play
here well you could move the knight but
there's no rush so what would you play
here even feel free to pause the video
and try to find a winning idea for white
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on spotting that the
knight and g5 can be given away and for
those of you who just want to enjoy a
show its Queen to c4 now there is no
defense against Knight the c7 checked
and black is just blacks position will
just crumble so each character sent g5
there is nothing better so nice the c7
with check King e7 in the now comes will
turkey played castles here which makes
sense.you castle and then you put
pressure on the f7 pawn but just because
the position allows it feel free to
pause the video once again and try to
find the forcing mate in three well I'll
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations as it's not an easy
sequence to find and for those of you
who just want to enjoy to show its
Bishop captures and g5 with check you
either play f6 and then Queen e6 is
checkmate or you block with 90 to f6 and
now comes Queen before check the Queen
has the block the King has no square so
Queen d6 and now Queen captures will be
checkmate
but chuckling instead went for castles
it's it's it's a similar idea now we
just want to play Queen captures on f7
would mate and here with f6 by Greg
preventing Queen captures on f7 mate but
allowing a different one which I'm not
going to even ask you to pause the video
as we've already seen it in the previous
line of course Queen the east six
checkmate so a very very nice game by by
vastly von Schuch
in nineteen most quite quite a
brilliancy
you will and the Gregg played a great
play the great game but it was in that
moment where he had to play Bishop to d7
that he blocked with the night and from
there it was just down hill but up until
that point it was a it was a good game
by both sides yeah yeah that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank your Lynch Melanie Guillermo muñoz
Beltran
Doug McNab arc Pike and Marko a pole for
conversion to my channel thank you a lot
I really appreciate it as usual you can
check too on my previous video serum
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
Lindo rossabi rapid challenge checking
up on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
such as this brilliancy here yeah thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your weekend